we'll learn more from these stirrups
later before we continue let's introduce
ourselves my name is Amir Scott and I
work in Google developer relations I
have mentored and work with many product
managers and founders across the world
and was an entrepreneur myself before
joining Google throughout this course
I'll interview experts and share my own
advice on how to build great products
and I'm Chris I'm a course developer at
Udacity throughout this course I'll be
interviewing startups explaining
different topics and describing how you
can complete the final project we're
excited to show you how to build great
products and can't wait to see what you
do